mittlerweile ist die luft superdünn und
wenn das jetzt passieren sollte dann
wäre hier abrufen die jungs von blue
reisen und ich wollte was verrücktes
machen aber irgend ein bereich in dem
keiner von uns kommen auch eine art aber
in die schweiz um ohne jede erfahrung
einen viertausender zu besteigen sie
doch so aussieht sich angestiegen
doch wie sagt liegt er ist die police
der ganze sagt wir sind mittlerweile gut
in der schweiz angekommen kleines
problem wir müssen mit einem zu kriechen
werkraum das war uns nicht bewusst
komischerweise um zwölf uhr nachts nicht
mehr wir sitzen jetzt hier werden die
nieren werden schlafen und werden morgen
um 5 uhr mit dem zug ein bisschen berg
[Musik]
hier läge der video beschreibt ist
tatsächlich übels das krasse produkt
aber der name ist halt übelste und das
habe ich auch schon fünfmal gesagt aber
es übel nahmen
du musst den namen ändern auch die
produkte sind wirklich gut ich hoffe an
weil wir gerne ausrüstung leihen würden
wir haben tatsächlich bereits ein seil
das schon nötig ok und just in diesem
moment starten wir absolut unter also
wirklich absolut also wir haben ein
bisschen ausrüstung dabei vielleicht ein
bisschen zu viel aber zumindest los
einheit vorbereitet
ich habe ihn angerufen weil wir gerne
equipment leihen wollen würden wir sind
relativ unerfahren erhöhen aber dennoch
hoch ein
aber ich glaube wir würden es mal
probieren sollten
[Musik]
um das war und ist wirklich dumm wir
wollten zweieinhalb tausend höhenmeter
innerhalb von 24 stunden machen auf dem
wert können und vor allem einen
gletscher beschneiden gletscher
verändern sich gletscher sind aus eis
und glätte haben auch spalten sehr
geschlaucht das ganze ohne plan und ohne
begleitung einer professionellen person
zu machen mittlerweile kenne ich das
sagen mach das nicht wir wollten aber
nicht hören und haben es gemacht
[Applaus]
hier ist sehen wir dort oben unser ziel
zumindest das etappenziel für heute
damit startet unsere tour offiziell die
jungs sind am laufen und jetzt geht es
darum meter zu machen
hoch zukommt bin super party am 15 uhr
ist eigentlich deutlich zu spät um diese
träume zu fangen aber jetzt geht's
richtig wissen jetzt jeder in klemm zu
machen mit rucksack übels teilen sie das
gemacht habt
[Musik]
am anfang noch komplett übermotiviert
die ganze zeit am reden irgendwie
scheiße machen aber je höhere kam desto
weniger wurde was gewidmet ist so krank
es wirkt fast nicht als wäre es echt so
es wirkt so ein bisschen so als wäre es
in dem film set oder so recht ein
drittel der strecke jungs für heute
frank warum zum fix steht hier in fahrt
hey das ist ein paradies für ansgar
schwenken müssten elektromotor das will
es ist abgeschlossen
[Gelächter]
die ersten 4 km geschafft man erkennt
das panorama hinter mir da unten ist
unfassbar anstrengend ist macht
unglaublich laune weil man die erfolge
sofort sieht weil man von oben nach
unten schaut die luft wird dünner
wir sind alle am kämpfen und machen
meter für meter meter für meter wirklich
schritt für schritt richtung gipfel
und jeder meter zählt und das ist das
was wir uns vor augen halten müssen
damit wir weiter vorankommen und nicht
die motivation verlieren
[Musik]
wir wollen jetzt was
hoffentlich ohne dass irgendwas passiert
ist das krass hier alter sie braucht
eine flasche die leer ist und dann ist
das gar
ganz einfach älter
[Musik]
schmeckt es ist absolut herrlich
keineswegs kraft kommt schießereien es
gibt soviel ian salz es gibt so viel wir
wollen hier
[Musik]
dank für dieses wundervolle wasser dort
unten sind wir gestartet ganz da unten
und mittlerweile ist die luft superdünn
die vegetation aber unheimlich schön
holen frisches wasser aus der quelle
lasst uns die sonne ins gesicht scheinen
ein wenig atem unheimlich spaß es ist
wirklich ein absoluter traum kann
wirklich jedem nur raten so was
auszuprobieren
es muss nichts extremes sein es muss
nicht sein dass noch nie vorher jemand
gemacht hat es muss nicht schneller sein
als andere leute ihr müsst einfach nur
raus kommen und das erleben und das
genießen
[Musik]
sind die echt schon nahe kommen
zumindest näher
es gibt ein problem was ich gehe wenn
ich so nach vorne gucke dann sehe ich
das so die höhe auf der wir schlafen
wollen schon noch schnitt liegt entweder
wir laufen jetzt weiter zelten im schnee
wo es richtig kalt ist haben dafür
morgen weniger strecke zu machen oder
wir machen hier entspannt legen uns
jetzt vernünftig schlafen essen
vernünftig stehen turbo früh auf und
können dann morgen und in europa kalt
und hell
also ich bin glaube ich eigentlich eher
profi aufschlagen werden dafür weiter
wird dafür stark machen weiter da graf
also das ding jetzt habt ihr noch übelst
power gerade also im vergleich zum
fahrradfahren an das ist komplett anders
ich könnte jetzt auf jeden fall noch
weiter es ist idyllisch aber morgen sind
wir auf einem gletscher also wirklich
gletscher mit spalte wir werden 50 meter
seil benutzen müssen ihre pickel werden
komplette ausrüstung das wird noch mal
ein komplett anderer schnack
das wird richtig kassen so dumm es war
wirklich wieder
ich muss das mal ganz gut sagen also man
denkt vielleicht soja der macht videos
das klappt dann auch immer und das
funktioniert aber ich erlebe das ja echt
ich erlebe das wirklich und auch genau
wie beim fahrradfahren ist es realtech
eine absolute grenze erfahrung und man
bewegt sich wirklich an der grenze des
für einen möglichen wir machen die
sachen aus spaß und wir haben lust drauf
aber ist es wirklich einfach unfassbar
wenn man den typen zu hören uns das
equipment geliebt hat es war eine
aufgabe von der ehrlich geglaubt hätte
dass wir es schaffen und
zwischenzeitlich habe ich das auch
gedacht also unser problem ist gerade
eigentlich hätten wir die tour heute
noch länger laufen wollen weiter nach
oben
richtung diesen kleinen haus das man da
oben sieht das ist eine gondelstation
und in der nähe da hätten wir pennen
wollen das problem ist hinter uns
das liegt mir keine visionen haben und
wir erzählten also müssen dass zellen
opening nochmals abschlagen und jetzt
haben wir gerade diesen sport hier
gefunden ein absoluter traum und dem
probleme jetzt frei zu räumen unsere
zelte aufzustellen und dann geht's ab
unser setup steht wir sind angezogen
jetzt gilt es zu speisen dann gute nacht
mit hoffentlich viel schlaf zu bekommen
kälte technisch schwierig wegen
technisch auch schwierig heute nacht
aber wir werden sehen
es fängt an zu regnen hektik bricht aus
wir müssen schnell in die zelte damit
wir auch über nacht trocken bleiben
unsere sachen trocken bleiben aber das
größte problem im regen ist eigentlich
nicht der regen oder die feuchtigkeit
sondern der potenzielle neue schnee auf
dem gletscher
er ist uns komplett vermasseln könnte
wenn neuschnee liegt sehen wie die route
nicht wir sind komplett und erfahren
dann können wir auf gar keinen fall
machen und wenn das jetzt passieren
sollte dann wäre missionen hier abbruch
und wir müssen irgendwann zweiten
versuch starten und das sieht leider gar
nicht gut aus die schlafsäcke sind bis 0
grad geeignet bis 0 grad und ich könnte
mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass wir da
heute da mal drankommen jetzt probieren
wir irgendwie ein bisschen schlaf zu
bekommen
morgen früh geht's arbeiter offenbar das
nicht anfängt zu schneiden und dann ist
alles gut
die ganze blitzen im ensemble der jetzt
hätte ihnen ist eigentlich vermitteln
nämlich käfer ich mich nicht hier mit
komplett übernommen und was danach
passiert ist und ob es auf den 4000
geschafft haben oder nicht seht ihr am
mittwoch im zweiten teil des videos
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
und das video zu leiten als euch gefällt
wir sehen uns am mittwoch macht's gut